voilà les titres de ce journal nous
commencerons par la décision de la
commission d'instruction de la haute
cour de justice qui s'est réuni à
versailles aujourd'hui et qui est formel
les faits reprochés aux trois anciens
ministres dans l' affaire du sang
contaminé dit elle sont prescrits
reportage de dominique verdeilhan et
jean cornu
ils viennent d'appeler laurent fabius
ils viennent de lui dire que la
commission d'instruction n'a suivi ni
leurs arguments ni les réquisitions du
procureur général pour les hauts
magistrats les faits sont prescrits pas
question de poursuivre l'ancien premier
ministre pour non assistance à personne
en danger je ne veux pas fait plaisir à
tous il s'y attendait c'était une
éventualité qu on ne pouvait pas exclure
parce que si la commission d'instruction
nous avait posé la question c'est bien
fait parce que cela posait manifestement
si on dit que pour les ministres chez
prescrit il y à une inégalité devant la
loi qu'il nous semble pas prendre sa
source dans des textes qui s'imposent à
nous une prescription conséquence
directe du particularisme de la haute
cour pas de pont juridique entre la
sphère garreta et la juridiction
d'exception le temps est passé en un mot
les parlementaires se sont réveillés
trop tard de cassation
indiqué que l'action publique été remise
en mouvement par le vote des deux
assemblées et non pas par réquisitoire
d'un procureur de la république pour la
haute cour le point de départ de la
prescription c'est le premier acte les
deux assemblées parce que seuls les deux
assemblées ont pouvoir selon la haute
cour d'inculper port c'est donc une
navette qui attend le volet politique de
l'affairé du sang contaminé au procureur
général de saisir l'une des deux
chambres et aux parlementaires de revoir
leur copie en retenant cette fois ci un
délit non prescrits le missile
involontaire par exemple que souffle
dans leur arrêt les magistrats de la
haute cour de justice d'où un nouveau
débat politico juridique sur fond
d'élections législatives et pour les
hémophiles contaminés
une seule certitude il y aura bien un
procès en mai prochain mais on y re
jugera les quatre médecins